no one's serving as a prison matron in
the state of New Hampshire
would you like to speak to you second
representative Rhodes
thank you
I'll just um add that I felt the
testimony was compelling I think that
indeed women have come a long way and
there's no need to separate and identify
them differently than their brother
officers so
anyone further discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes
representative patusic
representative Hill
rep
resentative janvin
representative Manion yes
representative Reed
yes representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes representative
goth right
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig
representative wheeler chairman Roy
gerbilts yes motion passes 19-0
19-0 the motion carries any objection to
consent seeing none it will be on the
consent calendar or hereby close the
executive session SB 29 open the
executive session SB 38 and I recognize
representative Jan from the muggamotion
thank you Mr chairman I moved ought to
pass for a second
second in representative tensor
representative Jamber would you like to
speak to your motion yes thank you uh
after speaking with my police chief
last well yesterday afternoon about this
bill
um
I understand that
is is absolutely true that our dog
officer has to have a police officer go
to the court to get summonses in the
place of an arrest warrant so along that
I would definitely move on to pass for
this
thank you representative tenza I would
like to speak to you a second I agree
with representative Jennifer
any further discussion
see nonetheless clerk to call the roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative petusic yes
representative Hill
yes representative janvan yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
Catherine
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler
chairman Roy
cheerful yes motion is unanimous motion
carries unanimously any objection to
consent
seeing none
it'll go on consent everybody close this
executive session SB 38 open executive
session on sp182
and recognize myself to make a motion I
make a motion of ought to pass is there
a second second
number representative manual I'll speak
to my motion
um it seemed pretty clear that this is
correcting an error that the Supreme
Court felt was there but they just
happened to discover 30 years later
um
I really that's that's all I got but it
seems like it's necessary
um at this point I do
overall would say that I feel like there
are some issues with the whole the whole
system of someone being able to pull
over and possibly not drive because they
realize they're intoxicated but that
goes to a different different Bill and a
whole set of statutes so in the meantime
we'll we'll um
we'll ask to as the Supreme Court asked
us to do and I recommend that you follow
and vote OTS pass
for the discussion
you want to speak to your second
representative
last court Colorado
yes representative Pratt yes
representative patusic yes
representative Hill yes representative
janfrin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative Catherine yes
representative Muse yes
yes representative Bolton yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair votes yes motion is unanimous
motion carries unanimous anyone object
to consent
there being none it will go on the
consent calendar I hereby close the
executive session on Senate bill 182.
um we're not going to take up SB 244 at
the moment looking into an amendment
I'll open the executive session on SB
actually no I won't
we're going to hold off on that one too
and I'll open the executive session on
SB 81 relative to interlock devices and
I'll recognize representative Rhodes to
make a motion
interlock devices is that one here yet
please hold
stand by I'm moving too fast
what have you done
yeah
Mr chair would we would it be possible
if we exact the next bill on the list
and came back to that
okay okay I'm gonna recess the executive
Chestnut just opened on 81.
open the executive session on sb209
is that the one you're good on yep and
recognize representative Rhodes for a
motion
thank you Mr chairman um I make a motion
of
itl on House Bill 209. sorry Senate bill
is there a second
uh representative Stone second
speak to your motion representative
Rhodes
yes Mr chairman so
I would like it to be known that I am
not I'm not making a motion to i.tl this
bill because I don't think it's
necessary
that
the there is a house version of this
bill that we worked very diligently on
with a subcommittee
and we had all the stakeholders in the
room and we actually went as far as to
ask how each and every single thing we
discussed would be implemented in the
jail or in the prison with that being
said
that particular version
seems to have a lot of support and the
consensus seems to be that that that
bill has stronger language so yesterday
while we were sitting here
I well over an hour looked at every
single difference on the two and it
seems to me that
to make the changes
if we decided to make those changes
would be a matter of one sentence and
one word
and I actually talked with the sponsor
out of respect for all the work that she
put into that bill
and when we we did not put a number this
is all important bear with me we didn't
actually put a number when we came to
menstrual products because at the time
we were asked not to and we were told
that the word sufficient was actually
going to be better
now it seems that it may be better if we
do actually have a number in there which
we're willing to do that we also did not
put about Youth Detention Center
specifically
because again at the time we were told
that the Youth Detention Center is in a
County and in the state so it would
still already fall under this new RSA
however after talking with the sponsor
she doesn't necessarily have a problem
with putting that language in
um and that is something I told her I'd
be really happy to sit with and work
with her on that in the event that
that's what we're going to decide to do
so for all those reasons I actually
think that the house version is done
I think it is something that we all did
together and we're all very very proud
of it and I think that the Senate
version needs a lot more work that quite
frankly I don't think that we have to do
we already did it once
um would you like to speak to your
second representative Stone thank you Mr
chair I concur with representative
Rhodes
foreign
thank you I'm going to just quickly
address address the issue on this
um
we did a lot of of work on this as a
subcommittee
um and I feel like
our bill was really good we sent it over
and passing an identical Bill makes
absolutely no sense we have we need one
piece of legislation to work with
and for some strange reason it happens
sometimes that we in the house will
write a bill and somehow inspiration
strikes someone in the other body to
write the exact same bill I don't know
how that happens but
um
one of them need not survive I don't see
the sense in passing another one and
frankly I think it just um
it encourages the same thing to happen
we only need one bill so I I would urge
everyone to earn to vote itl on this
bill and let's work on the bill that we
put all the time and effort into
thank you
further discussion
representative Muse
yeah thank you in in situations like
this I mean we we do have a choice
um we can itl a bill and get rid of it
which basically gets rid of the bill
um we also have the option uh to retain
it because we never really have any idea
what the other body is going to do with
the bill when we send it to them
um they could turn around and do the
same thing
and I think one of the things
um I thought that our work on on on on
the house bill was you know maybe one of
our best moments we really got to the
heart of the issue and I think we sent a
very good build of the floor and we sent
a very good bill uh to the Senate but
again
we we never quite know what the other
body is going to do with a bill and uh
by retaining it
um if something
untoward does happen to the bill we have
an option to do something in the second
year and and given
the severity of of the problem and and I
I just think the
I think we were all in a in a State of
Shock when we heard the testimony that
things like that were actually going on
in our state or actually in our County
prison system it seems like the state
prison uh doesn't really have uh have
this issue as much but
I I think part of it is just from the
standpoint of
looking at um you know the risk of
something like this not going through it
might be a better option to retain it
thank you representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman in
I do recognize everything that you're
that you're you're speaking to
representative Muse and I and I agree
stop the earth I agree with you
representative Muse
and but I think that it's important to
understand that after yesterday's
hearing and during the hearing
it it was made evidently clear
to a lot of Representatives in this room
that the intention was for us to make
the Senate version what the house
version was
and respectfully
we already did this work once it and it
really is a really good piece of
legislation that I quite frankly never
would have thought of I'm glad that it
came to us and we did the work
that bill is going to the house
with crazy support I've never saw
anything like it to be honest with you
and
I don't feel that it's our
responsibilities committee to take it
upon ourselves to make another bill
identical that that was not what our job
was we did what our job is and we did it
well
yeah
okay I don't think anyone's going to uh
be swayed on this um so who who's left
up representative say like go ahead
thank you very much I I just want to say
the one
the one difference between the two is I
believe the Senate version has the FN
and the version that we sent through I
think did not so in terms of supporting
retaining it my concern is if the Senate
should come back and say that there
should have been a fiscal note
and block it for that reason if we've
retained this version we can still it
didn't or did they
there's not oh I'm sorry I thought there
was I apologize I withdraw my comments
no there's uh there's no fiscal mode
otherwise it would have been a
constitutional violation that's okay
um yeah it's I I just um I I hate
politics Canadian in the way of politics
so uh I'm going to uh ask the clerk to
call the rule
uh who was left if somebody left oh I'm
sorry I missed uh representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman um it would seem
to me if the house has already made its
position known and it wasn't itl'd it
was passed then there would be no reason
for a if if something untoward happened
in the Senate there would be no reason
why the same bill couldn't be filed next
year we have a house position so it's
only the Senate that uh
the house would if the Senate killed our
bill
um there would be still no reason why we
couldn't submit it again for next year
so there's nothing to be gained by the
retain that I can see yeah that's
correct if if it passes our body we
could bring it up again uh just as
quickly as we could the retained Bill
and frankly there would be no reason for
the Senate to kill it if they already
passed it or something a little actually
not as good as ours so yes
representative Bolden
I just want to mention that um in my
first term I filed a bill that was
similar an intent but not wording as a
bill filed by a senator
the chair of the committee in the Senate
that my bill went to after passed the
house had beef with the senator who'd
filed a similar bill
so they amended my bill to have the
Senate wording
and then when the Senate bill came and
they killed it so you never know the
Dynamics
it here or in the senate or what
someone's reasoning might be it was a
great win for me but I'm sure that the
senator got the shaft was pretty
disappointed
um but I think that there's no harm in
retaining
um because you can always kill something
the the harm in retaining is that that
we already have I think six or seven
bills retained that I'd have to assign
subcommittees to and we have to come up
with a product
we've already there's no work left to do
on it so the retain would only be a
political move and um uh frankly I just
like again I don't see the logic behind
it we passed it we did the work
um and it was made abundantly clear
because I agree with you you don't know
what could happen or but on this one we
do because we were told that the intent
was to make the Senate Bill the one and
frankly
um our bills are fired filed much
earlier than theirs
and our bills are not a grocery store
just can't go shopping for which one you
like and copy it so
please call the roll
Mr Rhodes yes representative Pratt yes
representative patusek yes
representative Hill yes representative
janfren yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzai yes
representative Catherine
representative muse no representative
Bolden no representative Bradley no
representative Murphy
representative Newman no the clerk votes
now representative Newell no
representative selig
no representative wheeler
reluctantly I vote no
uh chairman Roy
Cheryl's yes motion is 10 10.
may I ask a question of the chair you
may
so
um I don't know if this is a
parliamentary inquiry or what but so
this is going to go to the floor no
recommendation if it ends up dying what
happens
yeah then at that point but what I mean
is
um representative Hill's point that the
house position is now and it would not
be able to be brought back
so and well that's what I mean anything
on that subject matter because the house
position and maybe representative Hill
knows I know he's really experienced but
like is that rule about subject matter
not specific legislative wording I see
what you're saying uh to be honest with
you I'm not sure I would suspect since
it's similar
um then it would not be representative
jambon did you have something after that
yeah my favorite one is indefinitely
postpone that means the subject matter
can't come up again
uh but for an itl they can bring it back
representative wheeler Mr chairman I
wonder if it would be appropriate I I
given representative bolden's comments
and representatives hell's comments I
would like to reconsider my vote and I
wonder if it would be appropriate to
move reconsideration so we may change
our vote on on that is there a second
second
what second somebody
I'm sorry I have a question again is the
intent to that's what I'm concerned
about I don't know if I was clear before
but if if the decision on the house
floor is itl on this will that
invalidate the previous ought to pass
that passed the house because of the
similar subject matter and then do we no
longer have a solid house position
that's what I'm just trying to
understand I've never encountered it I'm
representative Hill what do you think I
don't believe so
um I think what would happen is um it's
it was the house bill that has the has
the ought to pass on it and I believe
without putting words in the speaker's
mouth but generally what happens is the
speaker
reviews the house bill and and it would
be the speaker to determine whether
there is a is a conflict in this but
um within the room having not seen all
I'm saying is if the bill is
substantially the same and we did pass
the house bill that would be the bill
that he would determine that it can come
back because the language is is passed
at the house level so that would be my
that would be my guess
me
thank you Mr chairman so let let me make
something very very clear
the the changes
that were requested
that we make to the to the version we
currently have
been started
and when the sponsor who is sitting in
this room goes to present the bill to
the other body
that Amendment will be in hand and
already sent to them
so that's why
I I certainly cannot predict what
they're going to do but based on what we
heard yesterday
that there they're already everything
that they want is already in there
and the couple of things that we were
told don't have to be in there we're
still going to put in there but with one
sentence and one change of a word
instead of having to do all of the
things that they requested so I I would
find it very unlikely that they're not
going to pass it okay um representative
wheeler go ahead I just want to add for
the members of this committee that the
sponsor of the house legislation wants
us to kill the Senate bill for the
reasons outlined yeah uh representative
um
Harry gathroyd has asked for a short
recess so I will give us five minutes
foreign
Senate bill number 209
is currently been voted on and the
result is no recommendation and that's
how it's going to stay and we are moving
on
uh yeah representative I withdraw my
motion to reconsider
and
yeah she does
okay so moving right along
yes sir
um we're still going to have to file
um
reports of the committee for both sides
so one is for ITIL what's the other one
going to be for one will be out to pass
whatever they want you can't make a
motion to retain no no we're done
we'll we'll deal with that um when it
comes to time right now it's going to be
a there'll be two reports
um our side will be itl and the other
side has to be a positive motion so it's
going to be either off the pass you
can't make a motion of retain because it
can only be retained in the committee or
table that would be it
okay
um
what's my commitment of this any
all right at this point I'm going to
open the executive session again on
SB 245 and I'm going to recognize myself
to make a motion of
ought to pass I'll explain it in a
second if I can have a second
second thank you I'll speak to my motion
um we had some discussion about whether
or not this was necessary at all in
light of the recent Amendment we passed
to the Constitution regarding privacy
the whole concept of um an entire hotel
list guests being available to law
enforcement to just look at for any
reason
for no reason
um we found a little bit
troubling having said that
um
I think that that's something that we
can take up or I will take up in the
fall after I've had a chance to confer
with law enforcement and everybody
involved rather than just
do something else now so I'm going to uh
we're just gonna go ahead and pass it as
it is if we agree
Mr chairman in the underlying bill
as it is
um is simply to just allow them to use
Electronics versus having to maintain a
paper book
um would you like to speak to your
second
you said it very well Mr chairman
representative I have an amendment
sitting up in community services for
this bill what does that Amendment do
changes uh
it removes the also known as
because it requires that the the legal
name be present on that list and it
opens it for a couple other law
enforcement officers
in light of um what I said I think that
we really need to revisit the entire
subject and I'd rather not just I'd
rather just pass it
um and deal with it in a separate bill
because I think that we need to really
examine whether or not it should be
there at all
um so I mean
given that we're running out of bills
that we don't have amendments for I'd
rather just move along if that's okay
with you
yes representative I'm sorry thank you
for taking my question I just it where
it says each guest shall sign their
legal name is that inclusive of children
it doesn't say um but I think
um guests meaning the the guests that
actually are the ones
signing for the room not the guests of
the guest
concerned because the language does
specify each guest so it it just leaves
I think the current statute actually
says that does it not
do you have the bill
anybody I believe that is the current
language yeah the intent is is the
registered guest yeah
I don't I don't think that the amen this
amendment changes I think it it's
already in the law this just says how
they have to do it representative um
Bolden I'm sorry I thought that the um
assistant for the senator wanted us to
pass an amendment that took out the word
sign
but I don't think any of us have drafted
it they needed one of us to author it
with OLS but they had already
written up written it up under the
Senator's name
okay
I will uh um recess this one again
seems we're moving faster than OLS can
keep up with us on these amendments
[Music]
um
okay is there anything else we can take
up while we're waiting for amendments
81.
devices now we said we're waiting on
Amendment for that one
okay
yeah
the reason I am I put the kai bars to
the uh
Mr chair
I just have a quick question did we not
get into the voting mode I thought I
heard a motion in a second do we have to
undo that I just want which one are you
talking about for the bill that we were
the 245.
I I'm just yeah we did and we are in the
process we are do we recess just yeah
we're recessing uh so we're recess but
we are in the voting mode so I'm gonna
have to withdraw my motion and entertain
what happens the amendment yeah just
wanted to make sure no thank you
okay thank you
um while we took a short break due to
technical difficulties
um as we rejoin our program
this spill
um Senate Bill where's the hotel one
um 2 45 I'm going to recess this until
next
week Wednesday or Thursday
we have some work that we're going to do
on it
and um in deference to the um the people
who requested it from the hotel industry
I let them know that we are going to
take care of the electronic issue and
our issue is more to do with the
underlying actual law itself and um we
will discuss that and come up with
something by next week so that is now
recessed until then
now I'm going to take up
SB 81 and I recognize representative
here at gathright to make a motion
here a second
foreign
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you
I think it was well explained yesterday
as to um why they wanted to um
make the changes
um to the levels and the agreement with
um what is that other group called I
forget the name of it
um the
Jacob gel call system yeah so
we can just move to vote on it
representative Rhodes would you like to
add to that
no way
um yeah this this seemed to be just an
administrative fix
um and I agree with representative here
Gathering any discussion
seeing none uh asked a quote to call the
roll the motion on the floors ought to
pass
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative petusic yes
representative Hill yes representative
janvin
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzar yes
representative gathright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler
motion is unanimous
unanimous motion passes ought to pass
any objection to consent seeing none
it'll be on the extent calendar Senate
bill
is closed 81.
and at this point I opened the executive
session on Senate Bill 76 and I
recognize Representatives
roads to make a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move
ought to pass on Senate Bill 76 and
offer Amendment
to pass with Amendment
2023-1258h does everyone have a copy of
the amendment
you do would you like to speak to your
motion on the amendment oh do I have a
second on that second second and by
representative here at Gathering uh
thank you Mr chairman so yesterday when
we heard this bill there was a there was
actually a proposed verbiage for an
amendment that was brought to us and I
took that amendment in
I took that verbage and actually made it
into Amendment and with that we actually
took out the words uh medical legal and
we just actually made it say death and
we addressed the the sequence as well
representative would you like to speak
to you second
thank you
um again this was um the medical
examiner chief medical examiner she had
some really good points and I I think
that it's a good Amendment so I would
urge the members to vote on to pass
or to adopt the amendment so I'll ask
call the rolling Amendment
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative petusic yes
representative Hill yes representative
janvin yes representative Manion
yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes representative goth right yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
salik yes representative wheeler
chairman Roy
gerbilts yes motion is unanimous
representative
I'm a lead Group whatever however you
say that the title doesn't affect the
subject of the bill the title will
forever be lost to history
yeah the amendment changes that anyway
that's okay
um at this point I recognize
representative Rhodes to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I'll move ought to
pass as amended for Senate bill 76.
seconded by representative Murray
any further discussion would you like to
address it we're good
any further discussion
see nonetheless color roll
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative petusic yes
representative Hill yes representative
janvin yes representative Banyan yes
representative representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes representative gathright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
salic yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy Chavez yes motion is
unanimous
the most unanimous sought to pass has
amended any objection consent see none
they'll go on consent
and this point I'm going to open
executive session on House Bill 251 and
recognize myself to make a motion I move
in expedient to legislate on SB 251 can
I get a second
thank you I'll speak to the motion
this um
this is an important subject and
as I said yesterday
um we we have
this would give us literally just like
two months and I don't think this this
this subject matter is is more important
than and deserves more than two months
um we'd barely get any any facts and
data together by then let alone try to
figure out uh something to do this
should have been a commission I offered
to make it a commission
um that wasn't well received this
committee
um I don't know about anyone in here I'm
speaking for myself we've already get a
busy summer with um retained bills that
we have to come out with new with
legislation for October
and this would give us until about the
same time to study this is you can come
up with a good report and recommendation
for legislation
um I think that if it's if it's worthy
of study it can be studied Anytime by
anyone interested in making a bill or it
could be a commission but frankly to
just pass it for the sake of passionate
and not do it the service it's due
there's people that are suffering as we
heard
we heard the member from the ACLU Mr
lecase tell us that's an important and
in-depth and complicated issue his case
alone sounds very complicated so um I
just I I think we would be paying lip
service to it in Little Else by doing
that
um so would you like to speak to your
second
no thank you open for discussion
representative Muse
I'm going to oppose the itl motion
um
we've had numerous bills over the years
that have come to us
um either at the behest of the parole
board or because of the parole board and
things that aren't firing on all
cylinders over there
back in 2019 the legislative budget
assistant actually did a pretty
comprehensive Report with a lot of
recommendations some of which were acted
on but the vast majority of them weren't
just because the report came to us at a
time when I think we also had just had
about 60 bills dumped in our lap so I
think representative Roy makes a a
really good point when he says we have
limited bandwidth and I think that's
something we always need to keep in mind
um but my impression after after serving
on this committee for three terms is
that the parole board is is undermanned
underfunded
um behind from a technological
standpoint and but one of the things
that was new to me yesterday
um is the fact that
um 60 percent of the people in our state
prison are there uh in part because of
parole violations
so in in a state where you know our the
main objective of our uh of our prison
system is Rehabilitation and punishment
is also something we do
um
It just strikes me that there are there
are better ways uh and and I think one
of the things we've been doing is we've
been kind of dealing with some of the
deficiencies and issues with the parole
system via a bunch of individual bills
um
and and I think we can either keep
attacking it incrementally and maybe
some of those bills are on Target and
others are not
um but one of the one of the things that
actually putting together a group to
actually study an issue does is it gives
you a certain base of knowledge uh and
it and if there are changes that are
necessary or changes that really become
a parent that need to be made then you
have a group of built-in co-sponsors
um and and hopefully smarter legislation
so that I mean the reason why we do
study committees isn't to annoy each
other and and to take away from our
beach time in the summer it's because we
have important issues like this that we
can lend our expertise to and and
hopefully move forward so
um I I would hope that we could uh we
could uh
reverse the vote thank you
and I I thank you for volunteering to
chair that committee should that come to
pass you're welcome
representative Newell
um I thank you chair uh I agree with uh
representative Muse and everything he
said I think you know at this point we
are being asked to act and um it is an
urgent matter and so whatever I'll be
voting in in against the itl in favor of
immediate action
or this guy's representative uh wheeler
I just want to say Mr chairman if this
comes out 10 10 I'd really appreciate
being on that study committee
um representative Murphy thank you Mr
chair I just wonder if the timing is is
the is the issue if maybe the effective
date could be changed to allow for some
more time given that we're at the end of
things here now and
okay based on the overwhelming urge of
the members to volunteer for this
committee I'm going to withdraw my
motion of itl would you withdraw your
motion of oh yes okay and I recognize
representative Muse to make a new motion
I move ought to pass
seconded by representative Murray
would you like to speak to your motion
or did you pretty much cover it
I think I covered it and yeah and you
can't get out of the whole chair thing
thank you thank you for your flexibility
hey I aim to please any further
discussion represent wheeler I would
just like to add for the minority that
Joseph laskaz every time he comes gives
very good testimony very heart-wrenching
testimony and I think all of us
recognize there are serious flaws
complicated flaws within the parole
system which need to be addressed and I
really appreciate you withdrawing your
motion of itl so that they can be
studied Mr chairman and I likewise
appreciate your volunteering as well
um
representative salik I just wanted to I
think you've filled the house share of
the committee but I'd put myself up as
an alternate
thank you
you still do need to get appointed by
the speaker I'm waiting to see which
Republican annoys me to get added to
that as well
okay
um so I think we've discussed that
enough I lost the clerk of Colorado
emotional floors ought to pass thanks
chair roads yes representative Pratt yes
representative petusic
representative Hill yes representative
janfran
representative Manion
representative Reed
yes representative Stone yes
representative tanzar yes representative
Catherine yes representative Muse yes
representative Bolden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative salic yes representative
wheeler yeah chairman Roy gerbilt yes
motion is unanimous
yeah unless any objection to consent
see none they're going to consent
calendar and I will um I'll I'll
seriously appoint that uh after it
passes the house floor
um what do we have next
way ahead of schedule
um we are waiting on I think one more
Amendment so I'm gonna say
um we're going to take a 15-minute
recess see if we can't track that down
and after that we'll be completed our
business for the day so
foreign
okay everyone
um we're going to open the executive
session on Senate bill
to excuse me no you got two six eight
um regarding the um pre-hospital
treatment for operational canines and I
recognize representative Rhodes to make
a motion
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion
ought to pass and offer Amendment it's
the new one that you're just now getting
2023-1259h
foreign
gathright
and would you like to speak to your
emotion on the amendment
sure thank you Mr chairman so if you
um
this meant this amendment is what we
heard yesterday and the only change is
one word it was on line 20 the last two
words say ambulance service and now
instead of saying Ambulance Service it
will read and no human needs transport
and or treatment
would you like to speak to you second
representative here Gathering
any further discussion on the amendment
on the operational canines
I'll see none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the amendment
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes
representative pacusic yes
representative Hill yes representative
janvin
yes representative Manion
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative goth right
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative salic yes
representative wheeler chairman Roy
Cheryl CS motion is unanimous
the amendment is adopted
um I recognize representative Rhodes to
make another motion thank you Mr
chairman
I move ought to pass as amended for
Senate bill 268.
is there a second
Ed by representative Murray would you
like to speak your motion
I believe we're all set Mr chairman
discussion anyone wish to discuss
representative Manion thank you
my only question is uh and I'm not sure
how this works logistically about naming
it
was it supposed to be named Max's law or
is that something we do here
it's in the bill is it in the bill okay
yeah bring it perfect thank you
and um I'm I'm
I just want to add that I'm I'm very
pleased that we were able to take care
of this so quickly and
um this is a very important issue thank
you
stand by
okay we we have confirmed that Max isn't
mentioned in the law
um so you know for a discussion I'll ask
clerk to call the role motions off the
passes a minute
nice chair roads yes representative
Pratt
yes representative
yes representative Hill yes
representative janvin yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tensar yes representative Catherine
representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes clerk votes guest
representative Newell yes representative
salik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy
terrible chess motion is unanimous
motion passes as amended
um any objection to consent see none it
will go on consent and I close the
public hearing on sb251
um for the information of the committee
we have a couple outstanding bills that
we're going to take up Wednesday of next
week with our remaining two Senate bills
um or three Senate bills I think
and those are the hotel guests SP 245
and the
um false reports of alarm
and that is sp 244. those will be taken
up next week in case you're curious or
if anyone asks anything further from any
members of the committee
retain is that the motion that they
would have preferred
yeah the motion on the floor on
representative on SB 209 at the house
will be
ought to pass because it comes without
um
without recommendations
okay all right
um
and if you made the motion today you owe
me the report
and
um
I will ask
the vice chair or the clerk someone to
um if you could let me know who all
those reports please for today and I
will send out an email if you get an
email that you have a report to if you
could please get it to me by Sunday I'd
appreciate it and um nothing else I
would ask
um if someone could tell me what in the
wild World of Sports this is
representative Bolden was this you
this did you do this right yeah
all right then
um we will uh take this and we will
retain it
um
and even further if not have a good
weekend everyone and I thank you once
again for another week of hard work